لإنزاله رحلة عمياء يوم الأحد في
مطار بارث بانشال التنفيذي في ميامي
وشقيقه يأمل في كسر
الرقم القياسي العالمي
، جاءت الفكرة من القصص التي سمعها عندما
كان صبيًا ، لذلك حصلت على هذا الإلهام من
قصة الهند للملك المسمى
براثوارت  شوهان ، لقد كان قادرًا على
التصويب وإطلاق سهم معصوب العينين وقد
اندهشت كيف يمكن لشخص
معصوب العينين أن ينجز مثل هذه المهمة التي
دارت حولها الفكرة في رأسه لفترة
طويلة ثم ضرب الوباء
بنشال دون وقت للتساؤل تقرر الآن
في الوقت الذي كنت جالسًا فيه في المنزل
مجانًا ، كان جالسًا في المنزل مجانًا
وكنا نناقش ذلك ، لماذا لا نفعل ذلك
بعد شهور من البحث والتدريب على
أجهزة المحاكاة ، كان من الواضح أن هذا كان
ممكنًا حقًا بمجرد أن بدأنا في
المحاكاة يومًا بعد يوم  كنا نتحسن ،
لم يكن لدينا أبدًا هذا الفكر في أذهاننا
بأننا يجب أن نتخلى عن منحنى التعلم ، لقد
جلبنا تحديات مثل الشخص
الجسدي والآخر مثل
النفسي ، والأكثر صعوبة هو
النفسي  الأول هو الخوف من
أنك تعرف أن عينيك قريبتان ، والآن
ستطير بطائرة يعطيني
أمرًا شفهيًا ولكني لا أعرف أين
أكون ، جاءت التحديات الجسدية
بالطبع هي الارتباك عندما
تكون عيناك مغطاة  احتفظ به قريبًا لبعض
الوقت وكل الحركات المختلفة
تحدث في الطائرة بعد
ساعات طويلة ، قاموا بتطوير رمز لاستخدامه
لإنجاز العمل المذهل الذي يعطي شقيقه
أوامر شفهية مع التأكد من
عدم لمس أي من عناصر التحكم للاحتفاظ
به.  يد في الطريق لذلك بالطبع
سيحصل على رؤية واضحة للكاميرا ولكن
الأهم من ذلك أنه في موقف أنه إذا
احتاج إلى تولي زمام الأمور إذا
لم يسير أي شيء كما هو الحال بالنسبة للخطة ، فيمكنه
فقط التحكم على الفور في  في
النهاية ، هبط الأخوان بأمان على
مدرج المطار ، ونأمل أن يهبطوا في
كتب التاريخ
وليس الطيران فقط ، وهذا النوع من
تقنيات الاتصال ، ويمكن أن
تؤدي جميعها إلى المزيد من الأبحاث في أنواع أخرى
من المهن أيضًا